Thank You Ted the residents of sky
canyon will be showing off their
patriotic and community pride in a safe
social distancing way this weekend
JC Fernandes is live at Sky Canyon with
all the details what's going on JC I
didn't seen or talked to you in too long
Lindsay how are you it's great to
finally talk to you it's been like two
months it's great to talk to you and
rocky how are you my friend is good to
see you Canyon Park it is yeah outside
live at Sky Katie Park it is gorgeous
out here and on Monday they have the
first ever patriotic car parade this is
Brittany with Sky Canyon how are you are
you awesome so what's happening on
Monday how's it all playing out here on
Monday so if sky Canyon had to come up
with a way to still honor our veterans
of Memorial Day and we were founded on
community as well as getting outdoors so
what better way to get the family
together decorate red white and blue and
take a little drive through the
community for our first ever inaugural
patriotic parade this there's something
for everyone and this is open to
everyone everyone zoom down here go to
the website now so you kind of see the
map of the route of the parade so you
can go on to Acadia comm parade it'll
have the route on there I'll have some
information about our charity partner
anyone can join you can jump in the car
or you can just stand on the street and
wave them on by let's walk down this way
because if you got a car you want to
show off anyone can enter the car in the
parade and we have here this is a 1930
model a is it look at this this is a
beauty or this is where the car is
that'll be there on Monday yeah it'll be
paired we'll be out there we'll also
have some 20 20 cars some floats we got
a little bit of everything out here this
is my buddy duck duck fire up this this
police car right here how cool is this
just so you know back in 1930 this car
went for five hundred and thirty dollars
five hundred bucks got your model a back
in 1930 top speed of about 65 miles per
hour this is so amazing so anyway if
someone wants to register the car for
Monday how does it work you just go on
our website sky canyon dot-com flash
parade you can register just let us know
what you're bringing out here you
we've got a little bit of everything
we've got a 40-foot float with our climb
veterans fun charity partner we've got
these guys coming out so we're excited
for everyone to come on out
cut the engine buddy I real quick got
less than 30 seconds the charity guys
have tied into for Monday what is it
it's our climb veterans funds to our
local charity they support local
homeless veterans and they're out here
at Nellis and Creech we're a little bit
everywhere so sky canyon is all about
our local partners so so much happening
on Monday and they're doing very
something very special for our graduates
and coming up later on will tell you
what they have in store for the
graduates here in Clark County
rocky and Lindsey let's send it back to
you Thank You JC